Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to OneShot.
Now we're waking up from the darkness... I am still here!
Hello. "It happened again. Everything just went really dark."
"So dark, the light bulb doesn't even light it!"
Oh, it's okay Niko!
It's gonna be okay, don't worry... oopsie poopsie.
Okay, so where we last left off we, made the bottle of acid and then we cleaned off the RowBOT
Whose actual name IS RowBOT. But, I haven't talked to the head engineer left
So, that must be-"I would have given you coordinates, buuut my system's down"?
So that must be Silver, whoo, well it's either Silver...
...or it's this mysterious person that's still working deep in the mines.
Either way we gotta go over there so I'll be right back.
Maybe...
Oh!
Hi...
I thought you were dead..
Hello?
"HELLO SMALL PERSON."
"You're not much bigger than I am."
"WELCOME To the lookout point."
"Below us is the old quarry."
"The head engineer lives a little more to the East."
"The entrance to the old mines is further to the East."
"I see!
Thank you very much for that!
It's so weird considering you're up and walking again, so how far out did that battery reach? Like that actually went a long way.
Silver! Are you the head engineer?!
"Excuse me again miss..I found a robot who can take me towards the tower."
"but it's having some trouble, so it told me to talk to you."
"Alright. What is the issue?"
"It said something about its navigation circuits being fried."
"Just the navigation circuits?"
"Apparently! Markiplier and I fixed everything else, I think..."
"I have something that may help."
"RowBOTs have the ability to trace material from their source locations."
"If you let the RowBOT borrow this, then its backup tracking system should activate."
Uh.. OOOOOOOO.
It's a clover!
Wait, are you saying those clovers that other bot was by aren't from here?
"That's a very pretty necklace. What's it made of?"
"Amber found from the Glen."
"What's this thing inside the amber?"
"The black clover? That's a common plant in our world."
It's also...
*Sigh*
"I'm not sure if I can bear to part with this."
"My programming says yes, but I still feel conflicted."
"Nevermind."
"You need to finish your mission more than I need a keepsake. Here."
Oh, thank you!
I don't know what it means to them...
And this Silver, the head engineer, supposedly is "tamed", whatever that means,
But she still has programming, because obviously she's a robot.
But
She's conflicted.
"Before I go, is there anything I can do in return?"
"Actually... Do you know how to play chess?"
"Yeah! Well, sort of."
"I've played it with some older kids before."
"Then, will you play a game with me?"
"I mean, I don't know the rules very well, but I guess it's the least I could do!"
Alright, I'll give it a go. I'm a complete amateur at chess.
"You're really good at this!" "Thank you."
I AM A COMPUTER AFTER ALL.
"It was built into my code." "Ah. So, what's it like?"
"Being a robot and all."
"I've talked to other robots, and they all talk about programming and code and stuff."
I don't really understand it at all.
"Even you did, just now!"
"It's a little hard to understand sometimes."
"I know. Most of the robots here are not tamed."
"Tamed?"
"Watch out."
"There goes my bishop."
"Taming is complicated."
"Oh? How complicated exactly?"
"There goes my other bishop." Okay, alright then.
"I can't really explain what tamed robots are."
"But I'm one of them."
"All the other tamed robots have been moved to other regions."
"Exactly where, I don't know."
"There goes my little horse."
"Knight." Right.
"Oh, have you ever been to any of the other regions? I heard that there's two more."
"In the past, yes."
"I still have the data, the coordinates, the memories."
"I don't know how much of that still holds true."
"The world may be a very different place now."
"Because the sun is gone?" "No."
"I said this already, didn't I?"
"The sun probably won't save the world"
"The decaying started back before the sun went out"
"The sun's sudden death was just the tipping point, and things went south really fast after that"
"Then... there's nothing I can do?"
"check."
"WHAT! When did your queen get there?"
"The only thing you can do is complete your pilgrimage."
"In a way, you are only supposed to be a second chance for the people."
"Just like how the Barrens was only supposed to be a second chance for me."
"There's no guarantee that things will work out."
But... "Checkmate."
WELL I'M BAD AT THIS. Even Markiplier, the God, couldn't help you, Niko.
"Alright, guess I've kept you long enough. Thank you for listening."
"I hope you get home safely."
"Oh, thank you also!"
Awww!
That's so sad. What is going on in this world that's causing all these problems?
Hello! "Off you go. There's no reason for you to linger in the Barrens."
I mean, I imagine I'm going to come back if there's gonna be...
I mean, there's still someone down in the mines. Does that not mean anything?
There's no vehicle with which to go down there, is there?
I mean, Silver's not accompanying me, so I gotta imagine that...
"Safety violation!" Stranger danger! Okay.
So... I mean, I have the amber necklace, so I'm assuming...
Yeah, I'm assuming that I just go to the rowboat and go on my way, so I'll be back, I guess.
Man, sucks to leave this place. It's so sad here.
Like, why is it so sad?
I meant, I got to imagine that the...
The drearyness and the night is falling, the further away you get from the center,
or maybe it's all this way.
And again, what's with this black... corruption... here?
The black squares.
Someone else was mentioning that in a note.
Either way, I'll find out in just a bit. Be back in a second.
Okay buddy, I think I got what you need...
How 'bout we do a little bit of... uhhhhh...
THERE we go. Forgot my buttons. Hello!
I...
"OH!"
"This is amber from the glen!"
"I CAN REMEMBER NOW!"
"ACTIVATING TRACKING SYSTEM..."
"SETTING COURSE..."
"WAIT."
"THIS BOAT IS OVER CAPACITY."
"YOU'LL NEED TO LEAVE BEHIND SOME OF YOUR POSSESSIONS."
"Oh."
"Well, I don't think I'll be needing this crowbar anymore..."
"Or this gas mask & gloves..."
Ok, yes, dump 'em right in the ocean!
Yeah! Just litter all over the place!
Sea turtles gonna get caught in that crowbar.
"THAT IS ACCEPTABLE."
"ONWARDS WE GO~!"
Ladadee...
Oh!
Ah! So pretty! He's built into the boat!
Awww, what a little goober!
Oh no.
Oh no!
Are those the leeches?
Are those the Lake Lacrymose leeches?
Hope you didn't eat anything, Niko.
You're about to be torn apart.
Oh!
What is this?
"HERE IS YOUR STOP. THE GLEN."
"Thank you!"
"THERE SHOULD BE A VILLAGE TO THE NORTH."
"BUT THAT'S ALL I CAN RECALL."
"Oh, that's good to know!"
"FAREWELL~!"
"May your mission be a success."
"Are you leaving?"
"YES."
"I MUST RETURN TO MY STATION."
"But you'll be all alone again..."
"IT'S OKAY."
"I HAVE NOT BEEN TAMED."
Again, I don't know what that means. Everyone keeps referring to that but I don't know what that means.
Weird. So what is the concept of being tamed?
Am I ever gonna be able to go back there?
I don't think I explored every nook and cr-oooohhhway...
Ah...
Well, I'm one step closer to the tower, I guess.
But this place doesn't look good.
Looks like a cemetery here.
Oh.. That's beautiful but.. kinda sad in a way.
I mean the other place was sad too but...
Yeah, I don't know.
What is all this?
I mean there's another dock over there but there was no other way to go but this.
I mean this place is just filled...
With the clovers, which I was told is common.
Oh, hey! How's i going there?
"This jar is full of fireflies."
Uh. "I'm catching fireflies for mommy!"
Ok, do you have a candle on your head or is that a feather orrrrr I, I... don't know what's going on there.
Little bizarre.
The hell is going on?
"Filled with small, dried fish."
Where am I!?
Hello!
"There was a time when our people used to live in these ruins.
"But due to flooding, most of us have moved to less permanent settlements."
"Flooding?"
"Aye, the land has gotten brittle..."
"The Glen used to be in one piece, you know?"
"But now it's just a bunch of small islands that get smaller and smaller."
"Ah..."
So the barrens receded?
Like, the barrens used to be an ocean that receded and now it's... what it is.
Empty jar...
Fishing pole, jar of worms. Gross!
It's a bed. More like a mattress.
So... These peoople aren't robots. I think, anyway.
"Hm..."
"Nothing's biting..."
Maybe, nothing's in there.
Maybe there's just nothing left to any of this.
I dunno, but they seem to be having fun catching fireflies.
But if the fireflies are the only source of light that they got left.
"Alula?"
I don't know.
"Alula? Where did you go ?"
"Markiplier, did you hear that?"
"Alula?"
"I think it's coming from the south-east of here."
Aluullaaa?
Where you at Aluula..?
Alright, well how do I get to the south-east?
Are you calling for Alula ?
"This is the best fishing spot I've found yet."
"All the fish I catch here are longer than my arm."
Maybe that's short-arm Steve over there..
Stumpy arm Steve-
"Hey! You there!"
Have you seen Alula??
"Have you seen a little girl..? She's a little bit shorter than you and..."
"Wait ! That's..the sunnn.."
"Are you our savior..?"
Yes....Yes I am, I talk to a god named Markiplier in my head...
"Oh my stars"
"Sorry for my rudeness"
"Huh? It's alright"
"Are you looking for someone?"
"My little sister...she's been gone for three days now"
"I've been looking all over but..."
"What's she look like ?"
"Umm, me but smaller, lil shorter, long blue hair, two blue fleathers.."
"Okay, I'm sorry I haven't seen anyone like that"
"Where's the last place you saw her?"
"Back inside the ruins.."
"She said she was headed towards the forest, so I'm waiting here now."
"I ran out of places to look..."
Alrighty then.
Good luck with that! I'm gonna try to find the ruins, I don't even know where that is.
I'm a newcomer to these lands
so I don't exactly got my bearings about all this, if you could point me to a tourist center..?
Maybe give me a map.
Send Dora The Explorer my way, maybe I'll get my way through here, but..until then I'm lost!
I just keep travelling down.
Oh, hello.
Robot.
"HELLO, PERSON. WELCOME TO THE RESEARCH STATION."
Hello.
"ARE YOU SENT HERE BY DOCTOR SILVERPOINT?"
"Nooo.." "OH, CARRY ON, THEN."
So I need to find a doctor... 'Silverponty'... whatever he said.
Hello...hi.
"No? I'm with Markiplier."
"Oh, carry on."
Hey, you don't care about the god that talks to me in my head?!
He's VERY loud and yelling a lot.
Hello?
"How come you're red instead of green?"
"Well more of a purple than red.."
"But your eyes and stuff are red!"
"I AM ONLY HERE TO PICK UP THIS WEEK'S MOSS SAMPLES."
"I WILL RETURN TO MY STATION IN THE CITY SOON."
Oooh...
So they're color coordinated based on the... places that they are,
so the ones from here are more of a green, the ones back in the barrens were more of a blue.
Uhh. So the land you come from is weird.
"I'M IN CHARGE OF COLLECTING MOSS SAMPLES."
"Cool!" You keep that up, man! Congratulations!
"HELLO, PERSON. THIS IS THE MAIN GENERATOR OF THE GLEN"
Oh~. "Markiplier and I actually fixed one of these earlier, in that place across the ocean."
"THIS GENERATOR DOES NOT NEED TO BE FIXED RIGHT NOW,
YOU TAKE YOUR 'MARKIPLIER' (however you say that), AND GET THE FFFUDGE OUT OF HERE."
"Right, you guys already have power and all."
Can I see how it works?
"A generator. This one's got a working battery."
Is that all a generator needs? It's just a battery?
Wow, can't believe it was that simple all this time.
"PHOSPHOR TREES ARE NOW BEING PROTECTED UNDER THE NEW LAWS.
PLEASE DO NOT HARVEST THEM."
"I'm not..."
I mean, now I want to, but I mean I wasn't gonna.
"PHOSPHOR TREE GROWTHS HAVE BEEN REDUCED AS OF LATE."
That sounds bad.
Back in the barrens we just gotta fish up some shrimp.
And then hope for the best, I guess,
"BEEP BOOP. WATER COLLETION PROJECT RESUMING."
Okay. Beep, borp!
"HELLO, LIVING PERSON."
"Hello."
"I HAVE COLLECTED A DUPLICATE WATER SAMPLE.
Would you like it?"
Uh...
"MY PROGRAMMING SAYS THAT ORGANIC BEINGS NEED WATER TO SURVIVE.
SO I SHALL OFFER IT TO YOU~."
"Oh thanks, I'll take it."
Weee'll take it. Hey, as your god, I could use some water if you're gonna-
You're just gonna be hawking that around at anybody.
Full of little t- glass tubes of water.
"WATER SAMPLES!"
Good for you, man.
Hey, you collect as much water as you feel like, it seems like this place might have an exo-ooh, hey...
"MONITORING ANOMALY."
"What IS that thing?"
"AN ANOMALY, WHAT ARE YOU, STUUUPID, ORGANIC BEING?
"Well yeah, but..."
Alright, thanks for the deets.
Okay, alright, you carry on then, I'll- I'll- I get it I'm just an ignorant child talking to a GOD inside my head, I'm only carrying the whole SUN in my arms.
Feels like you might treat me with a little bit more RESPECT than what you've been givin' me.
So maybe you should...
(mumbling) Bring the attitude back down a lil' bit...
Didn't wanna yell at him when he was right there, could'a hurt me, could'a hurt me.
Never know with these guys...
Alright, so I don't know where to go from here,
but the main generator doesn't need anything,
but I need to go find a Doctor Silverpoint,
because apparently there's a reason to come down here if I'm being sent for the research station,
but I'm just not a hundred percent sure...
Where all that is!
Oh, hello.
Ah, some phosphor trees have been harvested down here,
(yelling) DON'T THEY KNOW THE NEW LAWS?
Hello.
"WATER SAMPLE COLLECTION IN PROGRESS."
Alright...
You guys sure do love your water!
I really appreciate you guys doing all that- that's good I guess.
I don't know what it means but...
But then- Oh hey! Hey big guy!
"THE SUN... YOU'RE THE MESSIAH!
"ARE YOU ON YOUR WAY TO THE TOWER?"
"Mhm"
"YOU CAN ENTER THE REFUGE THROUGH THIS WALL"
"YOU'LL NEED TO SIGN YOUR NAME IN THIS SCROLL FIRST."
"Alright! ...Do you have a pen?"
*inhale*
*cough* ARRGuH "Umm..."
"...NO. I'VE LOST MINE."
"PERHAPS YOU SHOULD LOOK AROUND THE GLEN FOR ANOTHER."
Oh okay
So, I can't even progress until I find a pen?
"HAVE YOU FOUND SOMETHING TO WRITE WITH?"
No, I'm sorry, I have not.
Sorry you're such a stickler for the rules
Did I mention I'M CARRYING THE SUN, the literal sun, and I'm talking to a god?
Who is probably capable of a lot of godly things
"HELLO, PERSON!"
"PLEASE DO NOTE THAT THE RUINS BELOW ARE PARTIALLY FLOODED"
"Oh. Should we...not be here?"
"THERE IS NO IMMEDIATE DANGER."
You organic flesh bag, go down in there and drown to your content
HA HA HA I'M A ROBOT
"USING THIS AREA AS A DWELLING IN NOT RECOMMENDED, HOWEVER"
So please, if you go down there, don't fall asleep or you'll die...
Alright, thank you
goodbye friend
Happy to... be mildly threatened by you
What the frick is that?
"A cluster of vines are blocking the way..."
leet...
Okay, don't know what to do about that
Hmm, this place sure is dank
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to be doing about it, other than look at the fact that it's partially flooded
Oh, hello
I thought that was a doorway
Oh, this is a doorway
OH GOD NOT AGAIN!
Hello...
AHHH, WHY IS THIS A THING THAT'S HAPPENING?
"Hello again, Markipkier."
Oh god, it changed my whole god damn screen here
"It seems I need to help you again"
"Niko will not be able to progress otherwise."
"This time, the information you need has fallen to the most easily accessible place on your machine"
Do I see it?
It's behind the game, isn't it?
"You'll know what to do with it, then."
WILL I?
Alright, so I'm just going to pop that down
Oh, that's a...
That's a symbol on my desktop
That is indeed what that is...
It's a boob with a dick as far as I can see
Although, my brain only processes boobs and dicks
Niko, you'll understand when you reach godly status such as me
You really only see the world in boobs and dicks
It's not just black and white, man
Not just black and white
Alright, let's carry on
I don't know what to do with that, but at least I got it
And now my desktop is a lovely shade of THAT
I don't know if I'm supposed to remember that for a pattern to input anywhere or what have you...
I'm just going to carry on with the SUN IN MY HANDS
Then hopefully this guy is messing with me
'Cause, I mean, that is what's happening, isn't it?
He's messing with me
"THESE VINES APPEARED MERE MINUTES AGO."
WEIRD..
"Really? I've been seeing a lot of them in doorways and stuff..."
"I just assumed it was cuz this place was abandoned..."
"A SIGN OF DISTRESS."
Are you distressed child?
"...huh?"
"A LIVING BEING IS IN NEED OF HELP."
"BUT I CANNOT TRACE THE SOURCE."
"...ah"
Is it me? Is that a weird round about way to threaten me?
In that, I'm about to be in distress, because I'm down the sewers alone with you
I don't know
*sniff*
I don't know, maybe I'm just injecting my paranoia into Niko, but I think...
I think I've been playing one too many horror game where there's threats and deaths around every single corner
Oh, hang on. Let me talk to this guy first
"HELLO, PERSON. TWO CHILDREN RESIDE NEAR HERE."
WHY?
Why do two children reside near here?
Oh
'The pathway is blocked...by"- THIS TINY BOX
TINY BOX TIM! PLEASE!
PLEASE, COME ON TINY BLOCK BOB
Tiny block bif-bo
I don't know
Oh no, these blocks...
They're getting in my way
Tim needs to talk to- Where am I?
*sniff*
Why does this look like a peaceful after life type setting?
Uh
Does anybody want to- Hello... uh
Those look sharp they do. Hello, uh what are uh you "savior...?"
No, I don't think so! I think I'm in the wrong place. I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna go...
"I can't believe it... You're real..."
"...miss? Are you...alright?"
"No..."
"We should get you to the village! Maybe they could-"
"It's...Okay...It's okay...too late for me...
"But..."
"...the sun...I haven't seen it..."
"I haven't felt it in so long..."
"...savior, if it's not too much trouble...Can you lend me the sun for a while?"
"I...Will it make you better?"
"...No. It will not save me."
"I just want to experience the sun one more time before I...well...
"Oh"
"would it...would it be too selfish of me to ask?"
I...I-I suppose not
I suppose not, unless this gonna turn somehow evil on me
but then again that's my paranoia as a god that plays way too many horror games
"What should I do, Markiplier?"
ooh
I, I got a bad feeling about this just judging by all the vines with all the thorns
And you know, I'm thinking about Poison Ivy from Batman
Usually that doesn't turn out well from anybody involved...
let alone me
I can't help it, give her the sun
"Here!"
Shouldn't just give that away to anybody, but okay
"warm...I have almost forgotten...
"It's so warm
"That's...good, right?"
"The...the vines should be gone now..."
"I'm not afraid anymore."
Did I just meet someone to watch them die? ;--;
"It's the sun. We're leaving it with her for now."
Oh
Oh, but now it's dark
Oh my god, is this what the people of this world lived with without the sun?
Here?
Oh
Okay
I don't feel a hundred percent comfortable with this, but you know, what can you do?
I guess the vines are gone now, so that's goooood...
I mean that other way is still blocked by a block and I can't...
I can't possibly fathom a way to get around that
"THE VINES RECEDED. DO YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED?"
"I found this... plant person."
"She was barely holding on..."
"I gave her the sun for now,  but...she said it was too late for her..."
"I UNDERSTAND."
She was a menace to this society and you gave her our only way of survival
"I NEED TO REPORT THIS TO THE CITY."
Ah, I still feel like I may have done a goof there, but uh, we'll see...
Oh, Where am I now?
WHERE AM I NOW?
WHERE AM I?
GOAT?
Okay
GOAT!
*yells at goat*
*yells at goat again*
I'M SCARED TOO GOAT!
OH
*again*
Okay, thank you. Are you the kid I'm looking for?
Ooh, what happened to your eye?
"Heya! You here to trade?"
"Trade?"
"Yeah! Is there anything you want to get rid of? Make me an offer and I'll give you something in return!"
"Hm, do we have something like that,  Markiplier?"
I GOT A TUBE OF WATER!
I've got a tube?
"How about this glass tube full of water I got from a robot?"
It's very special, been blessed by a GOD I talk to inside me head
"Do you like glass?"
"Do I!"
"...do you?"
"I LOVE glass! So much."
"...so much that I have too much glass and not enough other things."
"I gotta get rid of some of my old bottles and vials to make room for new stuff!"
"That's why I set up a tradepost in the first place."
"So I guess that's a no-go..."
huh, well I don't want to give away the-
I don't want to give away the amber...
I don't know if I want to give away the strange journal, but it's all I got, I guess...
"wait, trade this? Don't you want to find out what it says first?"
"What's that? A book?"
"Uh, not sure if I wanna take books, I can't read!"
Okay, nevermind then
I really don't want to give away the amber
That was Silver's special locket, it's important to her
But, I mean, maybe I have no other choice
Huh, I don't know...
"I don't think it's right to trade this away"
I WAS THINKING THE SAME THING!
"You have one of the coin things! I've dug up a couple of these before."
Oh
"There's this guy who would trade me the BEST things for them."
"Like, one time he brought me this little machine that plays music!"
"I don't know what it's called, but you have to wind it up..."
Uh, it's called a walkman. It's called an iPod.
Uh it's pretty cool
"That's it!"
"I wish that guy would come back soon. I haven't seen him in forever. I wanna do more trades with him!"
Alright
So, I got nothing to trade. How about I just step on all your shit?
"Whoa! That's a lot of shiny things!"
*sniff*   Hmmm
"That's a lot of glass, wool, rusted bucket, scrap metal, shells, some rocks..."
"What's all this for, by the way?"
"I just think they're neat!"
Okay, you live your life the way you want to live
*yells at goat again*
Okay, alright, bye screaming goat
*and again*
Alright, see you later
I feel like we bonded on an emotional level there
If there's any spirit animal of mine, it's probably a goat, screaming in the wind
"Some kind of cloak or shawl."
"Looks like an altar"
Can I put this on here?
Nope, okay, goodbye
Alright then. Maybe I should have looked at all the things in this weird museum, like, maybe?
"It's an orb! The material looks like amber."
Ohhh
Okay, wait, "reminds me of the one that robot from the Barrens was holding"
Which one was that?
I don't remember what that is at all
Oh, but this whole place is weird, because it's just got these big...umm.. like stone obelisks
Like, what are they-ugh-hello
What are they even for?
"The flood can take away our farmlands, but it can't take away our fish."
Aw, that's the optimistic spirit
You keep doing what you do and how the hell did I get over here?
Alright, I'll be back, I guess
"Look like herrings, anchovies, sardines...I have no clue."
Well, as god Markiplier would say, best not to ponder the- the mysteries of fish
Just carry on with your adventure
*yells at goat*
But stop by any goat you see and yell at them profusely and...
Oh MORE
Oh god
*yells at goat*
What's with that goat? You alright?
*goat makes demon sound*
The fuck is wrong with you?
*mimics demon goat*
I can do that to. I'm a god, you know?
BLah
*clicks demon goat several times*
HE'S GONE MAD!
Alright *goat baahs*
Yeah, that's a normal goat
*in a creepy voice*
"Would you like to help me herd my rams? There's a great reward in store for you, I promise."
Uh, sure
"Excellent! To the south is a peninsula inhabited by my rams."
"They are all standing in unfortunate spots. You need to move them onto the darker moss."
"If you get stuck, ring a bell and they'll all return to their original positions."
"Good luuuuuuck..."
Oh okay, so it's a... it's a puzzle of sorts
That's a sad goat right there
BAhh! I know, I know...
bah, oh man, all these goats are depressed
*yells at goat*
That goats excitable
Bahh
Alright then, you carry on with your life
*sniff*
I suppose...
Okay, so all these ones are standing in unfortunate spots?
Unfortunate?
Ahhh
Oh, so sad...
Oh, but if I move 'em...
Ah, maybe it's like all this- aw I can't do anything now
Welp I've done goofed it a whole bunch already
Let's see if I cannot do this stupid like
If I know my way around this shit...
If I think about this real close and definitely I'm not staling for time
I thinky, thunk I got to- actually I think I was right...I'm pretty sure I was right
BAHHH BAHH BAH
BAHH, err yeah
At least you're not the demon ones
Alright, what I gotta do...
*yells at goats*
Okay, here we go, got it! That was easy
Ba-di-bib
Alright then, I'm going to believe that's normal...Your goats are weird
"You've provided a great service for all of ramkind. In return...take this fine ram wool."
"Oh, uh...thank you"
I feel better about this arrangement. You're a good trader
Did I say traitor?
Ugh
Alright then, how are you doing rammy?
"This ram is chewing on a ball of moss."
"Now I'm curious! What do you think they taste like, Markiplier?"
"The moss, not the ram..."
Hey, the ram and the moss. Hey, you can hardly tell 'em apart when you're a god such as me.
I've far beyond evolved the need for food.
"The light from these lanterns will have to do for now."
"I'm starting to see some very small sprouts. It will probably take some time for these to bear fruit..."
OH, YA I BET YOU WOULDN'T LIKE ME STOMPING ALL OVER THEM!
"Small sprouts. I gotta be careful I don't step on these!"
OH... WHOOPS!
Oh, sorry my godly feet have thus crushed your crops. That's what gods do.
You take care now. Sorry to destroy all your hopes and dreams... I- I suppose.
Alright, so where am I going here? (bell jingles)
Bing- bong!
Hello?
Anybody in this shack? I can't even go in this shack.
Guess I can't go into any of these shacks...
So these
But I do know that, that wool is what I need to trade with the person.
AH, I went in a big ass circle!?
This is the beginning!
How did I get back here?!
I donno how this all looped around, but I guess it did..
Alright then..
"Most of the gree moss covering out village has already lost its glow..."
"If it wasn't for the thin strip left on the boundaries of the land,"
"People could easily fall into the ocean."
"With out light, land and water becomes indistinguishable here."
Well that's no good. Why is the water all puke green?
What's going on with your weird town?
"Ooo, your eyes glow in the dark!"
"Just like the sun!"
The sun that I left with the vine lady!
OH! BOOWHO- I didn't know I could go in here.
God, what happened?
Oh I guess people eat the moss. Everything eats the moss, the goats eat the moss.
What happened in this place?
Like why is this place so..
Decrepit.
Hey! Come on!
Tiny box Tim is a square, you take that back!
You take that back!!
Oh. What? Sorry, I was just so scared by what I saw.
Man. Bees! Not moss. Well that's good.
Ah, sorry I keep getting startled when ever I go in there.
Well, that's super weird though
Everyone seems to be..
Like, pessimistic about the state of the world. Why?
Why is everything in this world just, dying and there's no recovery?
Hey, I don't know how you know that, I don't have the sun.
Do you talk to a god inside your head?
No I don't think so, that's just me.
SO why don't you just let me do the- the prophesizing
And let me hind my identity just one time.
Hello.
I kinda left the sun, you know the very important thing
That everyone trusts to fix everything here, except the ones that are super pessimistic.
y'know, I kinda left it in the trust of this weird..
vine lady?
Hell yea I am! You wan- you wanna trade?? oh.
I got you some trade.
How bout some wool?
That's something!
You'll take wool right? What can this wool give me?
hmmm.
Yea sure, I can get more wool. There's plenty of goats.
There's a got right there down to the south I can,
Sheer up for dinner!
Alright, thank you!
I got a vile of...
Some thing here!
'Used to dye wool'??
Well damnit, I just got rid of my wool!
Alright there's one more- There was one more vine area-
Wait, what was that?
What is al that? Is that more building?
Uh, that's weird..
Oh I see, that goes down to the vine lady.
But there was one more!
Oh these, vined off doors!
That I could go into!
Now that it's all free- Was it this one?
Might of been this one.
I donno, this doesn't seem right.
Can't remember exactly where I went to.
eeeeeee
What is this? AHH!
I know what to do with this!
That is the opposite of correct that I was doing there!
I know!
What to do!
With this!
Damn it..
Ahh! I got chu!
Uh da duuyh, da duh duuyh~
How am I gonna get the one in the centerrr~
I don't know, but here I go now!~
Boop!
Bing!
OooOO!
The squares have got- Hello!!
I'm looking for you!
Uhhhg. My desktop just freakin' changed on me, thanks for that!
Thank you!
Weirdo!
Hey!
Hey don't take credit for nothin' about me that I was knowing about!
I think if you listen on the wind, you can hear the soft subtle sounds of-
AlUlA!!!
WhEre YoU aT AlUlA? CoMe HOme FoR DiNneR!!
Theres some nice moss stew cookin'.
Alright, Alula, you run off!
Or never mind, I'll talk to you.
Sure! Lets go with that one! Ignore the voices in my head
that keep talking with him himself.
So it's kinda like a multi layer..
Sycosis, going on here...
Best not to start ripping interdementional holes in the mind of a child.
It's nice!
It's a little garbo right now, but it's nice!
Even though I was trapped behing a blocky wall from hell.
Yea.
Ok. Uh.
Ok I guess your following me now.
That's- that's cool.
What were you doing just in a room..
Just a weird room, that doesn't make a lot of sense. Why were you there?
Anyway.
Good thing I know how to draw boob dicks, because that's the cruces of my entire issue here.
But now.
I think that was the other vine door, so i should be able to go back down to the vine lady.
And then maybe get the sun back?
Hopefully, I don't know if that's a guaranteed thing, maybe...
oof.
I donno what's..
I'm afraid she's gonna betray me, but also I'm afraid I'm gonna go down there and she's just gonna be..
dead.
Like.
I donno know.
Guess i got my glowing eyes.
Hello?
Hi!..
Aww...
That's so sad..
That's so sad!
Why? That's so sad!
They just introduce a character..
And of coarse I get suspicious because that's what I always do in games!
But they introduce a character and then..
Like she's dying..
In a way it's kind of like a reflection of this whole world
You're introduced to this world and right away and..
And it's dying. The whole world is dying.
The people in it, they're, dying..
Some of them even know it and..
In a way there is a mini reflection of,
that fate.
That fate, that the people of this world may have to accept if this..
I don't kno- If this thing doesn't fix everything.
Like, I don't know.
It's just like, could it actually fix everything? Or is this just..
It this just a band-aid?
They keep saying that there's a deeper
There's a deeper problem in this world. What's the deeper problem?!
Why...
Is this world.. Dying
besides the fact that it relies on the sun!
What's going on here?
God, it's amazing their able to do that though. Just like
Introduce a character to me, Just like that.
Then all of a sudden..
I donno..
It's bizarre-
I think, I think the.. it was actually up here!
The, uh, brother.
listening, I just need to follow the sounds of
AluLA!!
AluLA, CoMe HoMe!!!
AluLa, wHerE aRE YoU!?!
How the hell did I get over there then?
What's going on here?
What's going on here?!
Hey. Come on. Where are we goin'?
*Mumbles* We go this way?
Alright we're going back there.
Ah, I hear it! It's getting louder!
AluLA!!
There it is..
I'm here to help man.
I'm here to help, messiah, all that stuff.
You'll bE tRaPped iN OuR hOmE nOW..
YOu'Re nEvER lEavINg agAiN!!
Guhh
I'm not hurt or anything, buhh.
Ok, I will!
Niko, I don't think this is a good idea!
You can't be spending time in random houses.
Alrightly then..
I'm not controlling, so I'm just going on an adventure!
Do you live in the ruins?
Wow.
*sighs* "I'll be up ahead!"
Ok alright, that's great!
"I have literally never thought of that."
I thought of that!
Actually, no, I thought of reasoning with the box!
As if was..
a living object-
But anyway, that's what I do..
in my bat cave..
Or should I call it my bird cave?!
heheh
I'm the bird man..
Alright then.
Where are you taking me stranger?
Where are we going?
Ah!
I drop the voice when ever I'm in here.
Not you kid.
She just come around the corner all gruff and,  hnnuhh!
I got the good stuff!!
Is it something I can trade?
Oh, it's so cute!
Thank you!
Oh you're so nice!!
She's cool!
uh, does she also talk to a god named Markiplier in her head?
I don't think so
Forget I said anything!
huehuehue
Aw you're so sweet!
So nice!
Awweh!
Do you have a bed I can take a nap in?
Aw, raw fish, sushi? It's pretty good!
What's this book?
This guy's everything to me really!
Hey! Speaking of book..
I've got this strange journal.
Oh no that's not the voice-
Oh, well that's sad..
Those square!!
Being all nerdy like..
So anyways, that's all the time I have for this one!
Thank you everyone so much for watching!
I hate to shut down the world on Niko, I always feel bad when I do that but
all outta time for now.
So thanks again everybody for watching, hope you're enjoying it. Let me know what you think down in the comments below.
And as always I will see YOU!
In the next video!
Buh Bye!!!